We've got our canvas and
now we need to start thinking about how we're going to draw on it.
To draw on the canvas, we're going to need to use coordinates.
Otherwise, how will the computer know where we
want our awesome drawings to end up?
In geometry class we use the cartesian coordinates system,
which looks like this.
The cartesian system has the X axis going from left to right, and
the Y axis going from bottom to top.
0, 0's right in the middle and any numbers below 0,
0 are negative on the Y axis.
And any numbers to the left of 0, 0 are negative on the X axis.
The canvas's coordinate system is a little bit different.
Here 0, 0 is in the top left, and our x numbers just get bigger as you
go to the right and our y numbers get bigger as you go down.
This is different than geometry class where number got more positive
as you go up.
So, they're opposites in a way.
Keep that in mind.
Let's take a look at a couple examples.
On this grid,
I'm counting ten lines as one, because these lines are too close together.
We've gone over ten lines, which we're counting as one, so we have x1.
And, we haven't gone down at all so y is still 0.
Looking at this one, we haven't gone anywhere on the x axis, so x is still 0.
But we've gone down ten lines or one line in this example.
So the y is 1.
For this last point, we've gone over ten lines.
So our x is 1.
And we've also gone down ten lines.
So our y is 1.
It's important that you get used to the canvas coordinate system,
because you're going to be using it quite a bit.
To get you started I've marked off three points.
A, B, and C.
See if you can figure out their coordinates.
I've also gone ahead and marked off the next whole numbers on the y axis and
the next whole numbers on the x axis to make your life a little bit easier.
Type your answers in here.